aprendimos que un nivel moderado de
inflación está asociado con una buena
economía pero lo que vimos en particular
a inicios de los 70s en el 73 cuando el
embargo de petróleo golpeó es que
empezamos a experimentar algo llamado
estanflación lo cual es esta
circunstancia rara bizarra donde tienes
inflación y está en acción ocurriendo al
mismo tiempo en la economía y ahí se ve
la combinación de las palabras ahora
pensemos en como esto ocurriría en
particular pensemos en cómo ocurriría
dada una sacudida en la oferta baja hay
hay otras maneras que puedes conseguir
esta inflación
si tienes regulación rara sobre
regulación si el gobierno hace cosas
raras pero el ejemplo clásico es una
sacudida de oferta y cuando decimos
sacudida de oferta es como un embargo de
petróleo por ejemplo donde de repente la
oferta de petróleo o algo baja
dramáticamente y esto puede ser quizás
por alguna emergencia o por un embargo
así que ahora piensa en cómo esto
afectaría al resto de toda esta cadena
donde la oferta de algo dramáticamente
cae sabemos que la oferta tiene una
relación inversa con el precio entonces
si la oferta baja el precio
inmediatamente sube y pensando en el
petróleo tú dices bueno eso solo es una
parte que manejo en mi cartera y cuando
manejo pero no lo es porque aún cuando
estás comprando una fruta estás pagando
por la transportación entonces el precio
del petróleo afecta a las frutas afecta
a la comida afecta a todo bien y
servicio afecta afecta a los precios
suben y si los precios de muchas cosas
suben en general qué pasará con la
demanda nuevamente vemos esta relación
inversa de precio demanda en este caso
la demanda de caerá y si la demanda cae
en picada la utilización cae y si la
utilización cae tanto la inversión como
las utilidades todo caerá a plomo y las
utilidades van a caer porque la
utilización está bajando y los precios
han subido pero no es un precio en el
que las cosas se puedan vender ahora los
precios son un gran costo
en el caso del petróleo el petróleo como
importe en los años 70 es por ejemplo
entonces los precios subiendo también
tendrá una relación inversa si los
precios suben el costo afecta a las
utilidades de manera muy dura y si todas
las cosas bajan esto simplemente matará
el empleo mata el salario y altera la
demanda empeorando la entonces esta
inflación es esta situación donde tienes
un tipo de choque en el sistema donde en
el clásico escenario económico le pega
tan duro la oferta que causa esta
inflación masiva en una parte de la
economía y todo este medio todo eso
compromete a lo demás bueno espero les
haya gustado